[Musique]
l'hiver a fait son apparition
à 51 ans françois périer et bûcherons à
la tête d'une exploitation forestière
avec son frère gilles il compte
aujourd'hui cinq machines et 14 employés
depuis 1981 c'est la création de son
entreprise il a vu la main d'oeuvre
évolué
[Musique]
or even de slovaquie là il ya camille ça
fait huit ans qu'il est là et mateï ça
fait la deuxième année qui sont ici et
donc le fait que les jeunes ne veulent
plus faire ce métier parce que c'est
trop dur parce que c'est mal rémunérés
tout simplement par rapport au travail
qu'on fait ça attire plus personne
[Applaudissements]
tous les jours dans la forêt ces
bûcherons observe également leur lieu de
travail se dégrader depuis deux ans avec
les fortes chaleurs et la sécheresse
l'été les scolytes envahissent les
forêts de résineux s'attaquant
principalement aux épices et à l'écart
seul tombe on arrache l'armée des morts
tout simplement c'est comme ça les bêtes
sont déjà repartis sur une trame et
c'est voilà après le ponde parce qu'ils
aient regardé il ya des trous en fait
quand il d'hiver après dedans
au moment de la pause françois et ses
ouvriers slovaque coupe quelques bûches
allume un feu et partagent un moment de
convivialité autour d'un bon repas qui
nagent soleil si le travail est physique
et dur ces bûcherons apprécié de se
retrouver chaque jour au contact de la
forêt c'est un peu la liberté était tout
seul
la personne qui est en baisse c'est ça
le
le cadre c'est très dur physiquement
mais c'est
puis place au débardage
c'est la seule fois où françois utilise
la machine à la place du travail manuel
car depuis ses débuts il a vu
progressivement la mécanisation de son
travail se développer au détriment de
l'écologie et de l'économie
la technologie c'est bien mais c'est
hors de prix trop cher pour
pour ce qu'on gagne enfin de commencer
c'est pour ça que ça attire personnes
c'est un jeune aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
qu'ils s'achètent ça il va bosser comme
un fou pour les mains payer sa machine
une fois les grumes sortie il faut les
cubains afin de pouvoir être payés et
les couper aux dimensions requises par
le client les camions en met maximum 16
mètres de long donc les bois après je
les classe je les cultures des classes
je les coupe ils sont prêts à mener il y
en a qui vont être coupés à 14
ça dépend à près de malgré les
conséquences du changement climatique
les bûcherons arrive quand même à vivre
de la forêt en revanche avec un trop
plein sur le marché et la perte de la
valeur du bois c'est l'économie de la
forêt qui souffrent les communes
forestières en première ligne
[Musique]